[Applause]
I'm excited to meet the Royals The Lion
King cast reacts to Megan Markel and
Prince Harry attending the London
premiere Simba look at the stars
[Music]
[Music]
I'd never even thought about beating
them or thought I would have an
opportunity to and they seem very cool
so I'm excited there's a lot of protocol
makes me think I don't have enough
protocol I don't know who what you need
to what it takes to create protocol but
I'm gonna look into creating more
[Music]
yes
[Music]
I'm really on their schedule this is
something that they want to attend and
and so and I'm looking forward to seeing
Megan seeing the American royal oh I'm
very excited you know bringing the whole
cast a lot of people flew out here for
this I've never been part of a premiere
so just dressing up like this isn't what
we normally do in Los Angeles but it's
great to be able to use this as an
opportunity to share this story with the
world
[Music]
you must take your place
and the circle of life